welcome back to law and crime daily our
next story takes us takes place in a
rural Oklahoma town last month seven
bodies were found on the property of a
convicted sex offender including his own
this week autopsy reports were released
to the public authorities believe that
39 year old Jesse McFadden shot and
killed his wife her three teenage
children and two of their teenage
friends during a sleepover at his
Henrietta property McFadden then turned
the gun on himself their bodies were
discovered by police on May 1st the same
day he was supposed to stay in trial for
child pornography charges he already
served a 17-year sentence for raping a
teenage girl in 2003 and was released
from prison in 2020. McFadden reportedly
told his mother the day before the
murder suicide that he quote was not
going back to prison and that he decided
to kill himself autopsy reports of the
victims were released on Wednesday and I
warn you they are disturbing all six
Victor items were shot in the head with
arm and leg abrasions found on the
suspect's wife Holly and her three
children Pathologists also noted that
the two teenage friends at the property
had blunt force injuries to their
genital areas police and Pathologists
believe the teens were likely sexually
assaulted the mother of one of the teens
is accusing the state of releasing her
daughter's autopsy reports to the media
before her family her attorney called
the move by Oklahoma quote yet another
example of the utter lack of sensitivity
to victims and families of victims
Dina when it comes to releasing the
autopsy information what rights do the
families have at this point
in terms of legal rights not very much
once there's a suspicion of somebody
dying as a result of a crime a family
can't even prevent an autopsy from
happening never mind the results of them
being public but I think the family has
makes a very good point about
sensitivity you know not everything
should be legally required I think this
is an ethical maybe moral requirement to
at least have the decency to release the
information to the family first even if
it's by 10 minutes it's something they
could have very easily done even if
legally they didn't have to yeah bring a
little humanity and decency into the
criminal justice system Terry do you
think this horrific crime could have
been prevented I don't know if it could
have been prevented but he was serving
already for sexual assault almost two
decades and the purpose of putting
people behind bars is not just to punish
them but hopefully to rehabilitate them
as well and you would hope that before
they let them out there's some sort of
psychological evaluation to determine
whether or not it's okay to put him back
in the community clearly it was not
clearly he told his mother that he
wanted to kill himself now granted he
did not say he wanted to kill others but
he sexually assaulted others he killed
his entire family and then himself so
this is one of those cases where you
think maybe something should have been
done yeah absolutely and our thoughts
and prayers goes out to those victims
and those families
welcome back to law and crime daily we
caught up with the former football
player acquitted of murder in Florida
Travis Rudolph says he wants to get back
to playing professional football now
that his legal struggle is over Rudolph
shot at men outside his home who had
apparently come there to harm him at the
suggestion of his now ex-girlfriend a
fight broke out in Rudolph's front yard
in the middle of the night Rudolph said
he feared for his life and the life of
his brother so he got his gun from
inside he shot at the man and the SUV
they were in one man Sebastian John
Jacques was killed and another was
injured a judge ruled at an earlier
hearing that Florida's stand your ground
law didn't apply since the group of men
were leaving but the jury agreed with
Rudolph that it was still self-defense
we asked him about the impact the trial
had on his life over the past few years
a lot of sleep was nice
a lot of
a lot of crying a lot of Tears I mean
it's a heart it's a hard and upsetting
feeling you just knowing that you got
accused of something that you didn't
cause you didn't start or anything like
just the fact that like I said just not
annoying and just knowing what you're
facing up against because if I was
convicted I would have been in prison
for the rest of my life like
so all of us just just really it's a
really upsetting feeling just knowing
that you're faced up against that we had
a fair jury we knew it going into it we
had probably one of the brightest and
smartest group of people that I've ever
picked as a jury
they really were all right people
um and I know if Travis didn't win this
case and he was convicted he'll never
get a better trial or a fairer jury so I
race had nothing to do with it in this
case thank God at all he was
clearly acting in self-defense and uh
the wrong people were on trial here it
was they should not have had Travis
sitting there they should have had these
other characters including Dominique
they're responsible for Sebastian's
death but unfortunately
in this County I don't have any power
other than to representative Travis if I
did I would have charged all the other
people from many other crimes that they
committed
let's talk about that according to
testimony given a trial and what police
found in their investigation
ex-girlfriend Dominique Jones appears to
have been the Catalyst for the deadly
situation Jones her brother kashan and
the man injured in the shooting Taylor
Robinson all testified at trial Jones
had discovered Rudolph was cheating on
her and texted kashan to come to
Rudolph's home four men showed up and a
brawl started here's some of Dominique
Jones's cassimony about what started
things and what her text to her brother
really meant
did you delete anything at all from your
phone prior to handing over your phone
to law enforcement yes so once I
realized Travis actually shot at them I
deleted the message where I said to him
because now it looks ridiculous that
this actually happened and then I said
that message
and were you upfront with the fact that
you had deleted messages when asked yeah
I told her so you told the detective on
the case yeah isn't the moral of the
story is that you sent your brother and
his friends to go kill Travis now the
more the story is him putting his hands
on me that is really the basis of
everything and I didn't send my brothers
to kill him you just sent a text to go
shoot up right I didn't say shoot him
you sent a text to go shoot up his right
correct let's tell the jury what this
shit is
when you're angry you say things I'm
sure everyone in this courtroom has said
something when you're I'm trying to
speak if you want me to answer your
question you have to let me answer your
question well if you were responsive to
my question I wouldn't have all right
answer the question please okay can you
repeat your question question was what
does mean in the context of that text
anything but him
Terry Dominique Jones the the
ex-girlfriend set the entire incident in
motion do you think there should be
judges filed against her oh definitely I
think they should charge her she had the
motive the opportunity the means she did
set everything in motion she told her
brother go shoot him up and frankly
that's exactly what he did he took
several of his friends there were four
of them so it's four against one two of
them had guns she knew about that and to
send him and all these other individuals
over there I think she should definitely
be charged with certainly conspiracy to
either commit murder you know absolutely
assault or battery conspiracy to do any
of those things so they have enough
information they should have gotten more
information during the investigation but
they have enough right now to have those
charges against her as the girlfriend
for starting the whole incident yeah the
probably could have got her a felony
murder as well well Dina what about the
four men that went to the house that
night to confront Travis Rudolph should
they be charged
I mean theoretically yes because in
order for him to get an acquittal he
essentially or the prosecution wasn't
able to disprove the fact that he wasn't
the instigator and that he had a
reasonable fear of imminent death so
that meant that the actions by the four
men and uh were severe enough to Warrant
um some sort of indictment obviously
there's only three that have survived
the problem is is if the prosecution
does decide to charge them the number
one witness essentially for the defense
will be the prosecution because now they
have this whole trial all the statements
that they've made all the witnesses they
could essentially just call all the
prosecution witnesses it doesn't look
good that the prosecution just tried to
say that you know Travis committed
murder and now they're going to turn
right around and say oh you know we were
wrong I agree with you that the
prosecution probably has got a little
bit of egg on their face if they go the
other way even though it might be the
right thing to do we're finishing
Today's Show in Los Angeles as The Saga
of actor and convicted rape papers Danny
Masterson continues while Masterson
awaits sentencing this summer his former
legal team also found themselves in hot
water this week a Los Angeles Superior
Court judge ordered sanctions against
two of Massachusetts attorneys on
Wednesday she says they sent Discovery
from the criminal case to a lawyer
representing the Church of Scientology
that move violates a previous court
order as well as a law protecting the
personal information of victims last
week Masterson was convicted of raping
two women at his Hollywood Hills Home in
the early 2000s those women and two
additional accusers are swing Masterson
and the Church of Scientology they claim
the church threatened them and told them
not to report the abuse the district
attorney said in an email that the 570
page material reportedly shared with the
church includes the plaintiff addresses
and police correspondence the defense
apparently used the information to
accuse prosecutors of soliciting false
testimony to convict Masterson the judge
said that complaint was quote
demonstrably false and ordered the two
lawyers to pay 950 each in sanctions
Masters in faces up to 30 years in
prison at his sentencing in August
Tina do you think the 950 in sanctions
Set uh strong enough message to the
attorneys who were shared this discovery
okay great question because that's
exactly what I thought when I read that
absolutely not in Los Angeles one hourly
fee of 950 would not be unusual so
essentially the judge is maybe saying
one hour of the lawyer's time they have
to pay something like this that involves
really a serious privacy issues and a
clear violation of the judge's order
should have had thousands and thousands
of dollars of a fine not 9.50 I'm really
surprised about the low amount here yeah
and especially I think that's that's
average the 9 15 hourly I feel like if
you're representing Danny Masterson I
don't think you're getting paid 9.50 an
hour probably a little bit north of that
but Terry if there had not been a court
order prohibiting release of the
information could the attorneys have
shared the information absolutely it
does seem reprehensible but they could
have here there was a gag order here the
judge did say you cannot share this
information so they violated that the
judge had to do something I agree with
Dina 950 is not nearly enough but what
they need to do is to look at that
information regardless of whether or not
there is a gag order if it's
confidential if it's privileged if it's
proprietary or if it's personal you
cannot share it even if there is no gag
order and obviously here there was
information that was personal it was
identifiable they had names and
addresses so they clearly even without
that gag order even without the court
order they violated the rights of those
individuals to have that information
shared so I think the Judge should have
done more here I think the attorney
should have known better and I do think
they should have been penalized much
higher than the 950 dollars that they
were penalized yeah I get it it's
punishment but I don't feel like it's
big enough of a punishment for me to
think well they're not going to do this
again but Dina Terry thank you very much
and thank you for joining us here on
lawn crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss Justice in America
foreign
[Music]